ce look est de louer mais ce n'était pas
indépendante elle été façonnée influencé
par la chine
des scientifiques en conflit d'intérêts
vous pouvez pas demander à quelqu'un qui
est directement impliqué financièrement
et scientifiquement de faire une enquête
de ce style les origines du virus des
révélations troublantes deuxième partie
bienvenue à découverte
[Musique]
d'où vient le virus qui a causé la
pandémie actuelle le strass cov de tous
s'entendent pour dire que son ancêtre
lointain proviendraient probablement de
la chauve-souris rhinolophe une espèce
dans l'habitat se trouve à plus de 1600
km de one la veille chinoise où tout a
commencé
la trajectoire du virus entre la chauve
souris et les humains à one et le
mystère que toute la planète tentent de
percer depuis un an
la semaine dernière nous vous
présentions deux hypothèses la première
accepté d'emblée dès le début de la
pandémie le virus viendrait d'un animal
vendu au marché one and how and lieu de
la première éclosion connu
et la seconde dénigré depuis plus d'un
an une fête de laboratoire elle vise en
particulier l'institut de virologie
située à wuhan
l'épicentre mondial de la recherche sont
les coronavirus de type strass
ces chercheurs y ont construit une des
plus importantes collections au monde de
corona virus de type strass et vous
qu'on a collecté des dizaines de
milliers d'échantillons provenant
d'animaux principalement des chauves
souris et des rongeurs et même au fil
des ans des milliers d'échantillons
humain à la recherche spécifique de ces
coronavirus d'agents pathogènes
nous vous avons raconté l'histoire de
ces scientifiques qui ont risqué leur
carrière et de drastiques ce groupe
d'internautes qui ont enquêté dans
l'ombre pour réhabiliter cette hypothèse
leur enquête a révélé des informations
troublantes
coli 19 à émerger l'institut de
virologie avant sa possession neuf des
plus proches parents du virus ils ont
choisi de dévoiler au monde que l'un
d'entre eux le plus proche il y a des
choses que nous ne savons pas et sur
lesquelles l'institut de roanne n'a pas
été transparent nous ne connaissons pas
toutes les recherches qui ont été menées
nous ne connaissons pas tous les virus
qu'ils ont dans leur base de gamers un
manque de transparence qui inquiète
contenu d expérience risquée menée à
l'institut de virologie de one des
expériences dénoncé depuis des années le
soir c'était du gard de fonction avec le
niveau de menace le plus élevé je gagne
fonction un type d'expérience qui vise à
modifier des virus afin de les rendre
plus transmissible ou plus mortelle
l'institut de virologie construisait des
virus chimère à partir des virus de type
strass modifié pour les rendre capables
d'infecter les mains bel élan fait huit
fois et sur les huit fois ils ont réussi
à construire deux virus capable
d'infecter des cellules
l'hypothèse de la fée de laboratoire est
longtemps restée marginale en partie
parce qu'elles embarrassent plusieurs
scientifiques et des géants
on dit bien des choses ou les individus
de toutes ces agences de financement au
moment où ils ont réalisé le lien
potentiel avec un laboratoire il avait
un très fort intérêt à lier ce lien
personne ne veut être coupable de
décisions qui ont peut-être entraîner
des millions devant nos yeux
cette semaine on se penche sur l'
enquête officielle menée par l' oms pour
trouver l'origine du virus et les
impasses scientifiques et politiques
auquel elle se bute une chose que nous
avons apprises de l'étude des origines
de l'aco vide et que l' oms n'a pas le
pouvoir les failles de cette enquête
font craindre le spectre d'un futur
possible une prochaine pandémie causée
par des virus créé par l'humain
[Musique]
en avril 2020 l'australie est le premier
pays à mener la charge elle presque ms
de mener une investigation indépendante
sur l'origine du virus
tout en de ce thème hu la chine en est
offusqué jeunes qu'aux fans sont elles
pénalisent l'australie par des sanctions
commerciales le ton est donné
l'environnement actuel n'est tout
simplement pas propice c'est mon point
de vue linfa one est un des plus grands
experts du sras son monde il a investi
liés sur l'origine de toutes les
récentes épidémies issus de la chauve
souris le nie pas le maire ce le strass
est à présent le scra skov 2 pour lui ce
nouveau coronavirus est d'origine
naturelle
reste à en trouver la source la
recherche de l'origine du virus est déjà
très compliquée ne serait ce que la
science juste la science si on joue à
faire de la politique comme nous le
faisons là je crois que nous ne la
trouveront jamais
en mai 2020 l'assemblée mondiale la
santé réclame l'identification de la
source au nautic du virus et sa voix
d'introduction dans la population
humaine
philippe alan sauce est experte en
menaces biologiques hawkins coach de
l'ombre elle conseille régulièrement
l'onu sur ces questions
l'assemblée mondiale de la santé a
déclaré que nous avions besoin d'une
enquête sur les origines de la pandémie
mais le problème c'est qu'au moment de
mettre en oeuvre ces décisions la chine
a exercé trop d'influx ans thomas il n'a
pas permis d'avoir une enquête
appropriée
après des semaines de négociations
confidentielles entre l' oms et pékin en
novembre 2020 le mandat est rendue
publique on parle à présent d'une étude
conjointe et non plus d'une enquête au
final ce qu'on a obtenu c'est ce qu'ils
ont eux-mêmes appelée un voyage d'étude
dans lequel la chine a fortement
influencé le mandat ou les termes de
référence du groupe
le mandat se concentre sur l'hypothèse
naturel du virus mais aussi sur une
autre hypothèse la voie des aliments
congelés vendu au marché aux annales une
hypothèse soutenue par le gouvernement
chinois
allait natcan et post doctorants au
broad institute associé à un om haïti
elle a été une des premières voix
scientifiques à réclamer publiquement
une discussion ouverte sur la
possibilité d'une fuite de laboratoire
l'hypothèse des produits congelés est
celle où des scientifiques affirment
qu'un bloc de viande surgelée
expédié à one serait la source de la
pandémie
c'est un scénario extrêmement peu
probable
jusqu'à présent on n'a trouvé personne
ayant déjà contracté l'aco vide d'un
bloc de viande surgelée
si cette hypothèse s'avère le virus
proviendrait alors des pays qui exporte
ses produits congelés ce qui
innocenteraient la chine donc nulle part
j'ai vu quoi que ce soit publié dix ans
que cela arrive ou qu'il est crédible
que cela arrive
depuis 20 ans le docteur daniel le psy
parcourt le monde pour se rendre au lieu
d'émergence des nouveaux virus afin
d'étudier les épidémies et leur origine
ils étaient sur le terrain pour les
débuts de l'ebola du maire ce du strass
du sica jeu plus important message que
le gouvernement central chinois
souhaitent pour l'aco vide et que ce
virus n'a pas commencé en chine
nulle part le mandat ne mentionne la
possibilité d'une fuite de laboratoire
eux-mêmes vie qui n'était pas vraiment
là pour étudier l'hypothèse de la fuite
de laboratoire que de leur point de vue
cela ne faisait pas partie de leur
mandat
pour mener cette mission la chine
forment une équipe de 17 personnes qui
devra collaborer avec 17 experts nommés
par le ms
mais l'om s accordent à la chine un
droit de veto sur le choix des membres
de sa propre équipe
les expertises du groupe se concentrait
principalement sur les who knows sur
l'épidémiologie et même sur les aliments
congelés feu à spec
cette équipe ne comptera aucune
expertise spécifique en biosécurité de
toutes les candidatures américaine
proposait une seule sera retenue peter
d'azac président de hickory or alive un
partenaire financier de longue date de
l'institut de virologie de waele il
avait aussi orchestré cette lettre qui
qualifiait de complotiste la théorie
d'une fille de laboratoire il y avait
des conflits d'intérêts évidents à
l'intérieur même de la délégation en
baisse les virologues français etienne
de creully et bruno canard étudient le
virus sras skov du depuis le début de la
pandémie il défend la nécessité
d'étudier toutes les hypothèses sur
l'origine du virus vous pouvez pas
demander à quelqu'un qui est directement
impliqué financièrement personnellement
et scientifiquement de faire une enquête
de ce style peter dale zac doit défendre
sa participation à l'étude à répétition
janvier 2021 un an après le début de la
pandémie l'équipe internationale
d'enquêteurs arrive enfin à one elle y
restera quatre semaines dont deux en
quarantaine
tout était planifié pour eux par
l'équipe chinoise le gouvernement ils
n'ont jamais été laissé seul dans la
pièce avec qui que ce soit
ils ont aussi fortement influencé ce
qu'il pouvait voir sur le terrain et en
chine à quels dossiers il devait taxe
est donc l installation et pouvait se
rendre à qui ils pouvaient parler ils
visaient des hôpitaux et laboratoires de
boyne un musée commémorant la guerre de
guan contre le virus
les marchés de one day one alors fermé
au coeur de ce voyage des échanges avec
les chercheurs chinois il leur
présenteront le travail fait par plus de
1000 experts et travailleurs de la santé
chinois avec des limites majeur
scientifiques chinois ont collecté les
données et sont les seuls à y avoir eu
accès alors tout ce qu'ils ont vu c'est
l'analyse de l'équipe chinoise mais ils
n'ont jamais pu voir les données elles
mêmes
c'est avec cette escort qu'à la fin de
leur mission ils visitent l'institut de
virologie médina et n'ont pas posé les
questions n'ont pas vu ce qu'on aurait
voulu qu'ils voient n'ont pas demandé
les dossiers ecce terra
en gros ils ont demandé à l'institut est
ce que le virus vient d'ici et
l'institut a dit non il ne vient pas
d'ici et c'est ce qu'ils ont écrit dans
le rapport voilà toute l'étendue
l'enquète
le rapport final de la mission est
publié en mars 2021 oui tout système pro
tools ou get this
thing de la route l'étude conclut qu'une
fuite de laboratoire est extrêmement peu
probable
elle est jugée moins plausible que la
voix des aliments congelés qui est
qualifié de possibles une transmission
directe de la source animale à l'humain
est dit possible à probable une origine
naturelle via un autre intermédiaire un
animal inconnu et jugé probable à très
probable
line found défunt sera pas il ya 17 ans
je faisais partie de la même mission
pour le premier sera ce
rapport avec est loin d'être aussi
complet que celui pour le sascoc deux
sets de table est chaud alors les
conclusions de l'om est sont très
claires n'est ce pas mais est-ce qu'on
avait assez d'informations pour en
arriver à ces conclusions
ce sont des chercheurs de très haut
calibre
mais immédiatement après la présentation
des conclusions de la mission dans un
volte face inattendue
le directeur général de l'om est en
reconnaît les faiblesses la chaîne n'a
pas partagé adéquatement ces données et
l'hypothèse de laboratoire passé du
10ème au dessus
nous avons demandé une entrevue à tous
les enquêteurs internationaux de la
mission ainsi qu'à l'om s tous sans
exception ont décliné notre invitation
[Musique]
les faiblesses du rapport sont
immédiatement dénoncés par une quinzaine
de pays dont le canada et les états-unis
et dans le wall street journal une
vingtaine de scientifiques remettent en
question les conclusions dont bruno
canard et étienne de creully ce rapport
dit que l'hypothèse d'un accident de
laboratoire est très très improbable
mais il n'y a pas d'élément finalement
factuelle qui documentent 7 cette
conclusion car si l'origine du virus est
bien naturel il devrait se trouver des
traces de son parcours
quels sont donc les indices trouvés sur
le terrain qui soutiennent cette
hypothèse
après la pause le marché d'animaux
vivants one premier suspect
le marché ouanane au coeur de one
dès le départ il est considéré comme le
lieu d'origine du sras skov de tout
portait à croire que le virus se
seraient transmis à l'humain par
l'intermédiaire d'un animal vendu au
marché c'est là où auraient été infectés
le patient zéro
mais d'entrée de jeu les enquêteurs le
ms questionne le véritable rôle du
marché dans leur rapport ils relèvent
plusieurs signes laissant croire que le
virus était plus répandue en décembre
2019 que ce qui était rapporté et ce
bien avant l'éclosion au marché one
aurait des
reliques sommes
une des plus grandes questions et quand
est ce que cette pandémie a commencé et
il y à un moyen de trouver la réponse
l'un d'eux demandé par l'équipe de l'om
est ce l accès à la banque
d'échantillons de sang
ou and blood center recueille plus de
200 milles dans par année qui pourrait
révéler si le virus circulait avant les
premiers cas rapportés
la réponse pourrait aussi se trouver
dans les soixante seize mille dossiers
médicaux de patients ayant consulté des
hôpitaux de one à l'automne 2010 9 mai
la chine a refusé cet accès aux
enquêteurs invoquant des raisons de
confidentialité alors promet des
analyses approfondies qui sont encore à
ce jour non disponibles
devant cette impasse les enquêteurs ne
peuvent que se tourner vers le marché ou
annan pour beaucoup encore le lieu
d'émergence du virus le plus probable en
en vrais scientifiques continuent à
insister que le virus devaient provenir
du marché qu'il ne restait qu'à trouver
l'autre l'animal intermédiaire
cet animal l'autre intermédiaire
porterait alors le virus progéniteurs ou
proximale le par an immediate sera skov
2 pour le virus pour lutter et le parent
très similaire aux rascol 2 à quel point
similaire au moins 99 pour ça en fait 99
99%
pour l'épidémie demers en 2013 l'hôte
intermédiares était le dromadaire pour
le premier sera ce c'était la civette
palmiste vendus dans les marchés
les meilleurs candidats sont les
pangolins le chien viverrin et les
civettes ont été appliquées dans
l'épidémie du premier sera soit le
problème c'est que la chine a toujours
soutenu qu'aucun mammifères vivant était
vendu au marché ouanane le rapport de l'
oms dit qu'on leur a donné deux témoins
qui ont déclaré n'avoir jamais vu de
mammifères vendu au marché et ce malgré
qu'il fréquentait le marché depuis plus
de vingt ans
sans autres vérifications les enquêteurs
affirment dans leur rapport n'avoir
trouvé aucune preuve la présence de mme
annie faire vivant au marché en 2010
neuf pour moi j'ai en cirque l'esa
souligné surligné en rouge en jaune
c'est simplement pas vrai et beaucoup de
gens savaient que ce n'était pas vrai
et si l'équipe de l'om s ne le savais
pas je veux dire il y à ce que vous
soupçonnez versus que vous savez
le 7 juin dernier une nouvelle étude
secoue la crédibilité du rapport de l'
oms entre 2017 et 2019 elle recense de
nombreuses espèces de mammifères vivant
en vente dans une dizaine d'étals au
marché
photos à l'appui d'un kill de l' oms se
demandaient pourquoi nous l'avez vous
pas dit plus tôt nous n'aurions pas
passer tout ce temps à étudier les
blaireaux furet congelés parmi les
mammifères retrouver des chiens vivre un
des civelles palmistes des visant des
animaux susceptibles ou sera skov de ou
impliqués dans la propagation du premier
tracé
lundi ce qu'attendait robert gary ce
virologiste est un expert des maladies
émergentes
il fait partie des premiers à avoir
examiné les séquences génétiques du
strass cov 2 pour lui aucun doute ce
virus vient de ce marché
c'est un indice très important c'est
presque trouvé l'armé du crime
maintenant on sait contrairement à ce
que l'on croyait que ces animaux étaient
dans ces marchés
comment faire confiance à la chine pour
quoi que ce soit d'autre quand
clairement objectivement de manière
vérifiable ils ont affirmé le 30 mars
qu'il ne pouvait trouver aucune preuve
de la présence de mammifères vivant
mais pour démontrer hors de tout doute
que le virus est issu du marché il
aurait fallu tester ces animaux vivants
et trouver des traces du sras skov 2
or le 31 décembre 2019 les autorités
chinoises ont forcé la fermeture du
marché et sa désinfection walker des
raisons de santé publique oui il fallait
nettoyer le marché le stériliser et
probablement le fermer et c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait c'était à 100% la bonne
chose à faire mais on se retrouve dans
une situation nous n'avons pas pu isoler
les virus provenant des animaux de ce
marché
le centre de contrôle des infections
chinois le cdc déclare qu'avant cette
désinfection 3 136 échantillons ont été
prélevés sur les animaux du marché et
testé tous se sont révélés négatifs
je comprends du rapport de l'om est ce
que les 3 136 échantillons ont tous été
prélevés sur des carcasses d'animaux
congelés du marché de wana et que leurs
tests ont été négatifs
mais puisque la chine n'a jamais admis
que des mammifères vivant était en vente
au marché ou à nam elle ne peut donc
être maître en avoir testé
mais l'élément important qu'il manquait
et qu'il manque encore à ce jour ce sont
les données sur des animaux infectés de
ce marché ou de tout autre marché on n'a
pas rapporté un seul animal portant le
strass cov 2 depuis le début de
l'épidémie
que faire alors pour démontrer l'origine
naturelle du virus l'autre piste à
suivre est celle de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement du marché ou annan
mais selon les témoignages d'éleveurs et
de trappeur chinois très tôt la chine a
ordonné la vente ou l'abattage des bêtes
certaines fermes qui faisait ce commerce
ont été fermés il ya eu un blocage total
de l'information
impossible d'échantillonner ces animaux
les gens se plaignent du manque de
transparence à l'institut de virologie
de one je dirais qu'il ya un manque de
transparence égal et probablement plus
important encore sur ce commerce des
espèces sauvages
les scientifiques chinois rapportent
avoir testé 80 mille animaux sauvages et
d'élevage et aucun d'entre eux ne
possèdent une quelconque trace de strass
cov 2 que ce soit du matériel génomique
ou des anticorps nous n'avons simplement
aucune preuve d'un autre intermédiaire
ne pouvons pas trouver la source animale
proximale d'espis russe et tout le débat
est là est toute la question est là
c'est comment ça se fait qu'on a pas
identifiés ces taux intermédiaire alors
qu'on a échantillonné +90 l'échantillon
est ce qu'il ya des trous dans la
raquette de l'échantillonnage est ce
qu'on n'a pas et championne et au bon
endroit rien n'indique que ces tests ont
été menés de manière systématique sur
les fournisseurs et les chaînes
d'approvisionnement du marché ouanane
d'ailleurs le rapport de l'om est en
fait sa recommandation pour la prochaine
étape d'une éventuelle enquête
oui
[Musique]
cette absence de preuves et troublante
surtout en comparaison avec les
pandémies passées pour le maire slota
terme et diarra a été identifié neuf
mois après le début de la pandémie pour
le premier sera trouvé cet hôte
intermédiaire fut encore plus rapide
ils n'ont confirmé qu'en mars 2003 qu'il
s'agissait d'un coronavirus mais en mai
il avait déjà trouvé de nombreuses
espèces animales porteuses de virus
similaires dans les marchés de pointe
dont
alors l'épreuve terrain était là des
virus similaire au tracé t'ai répondu
dans la communauté du commerce animal de
guang dong
pour le strass 2 ils n'ont rien de cela
on a bien trouvé récemment dans des
chauves souris au laos à 2000 km2 où
anne plusieurs virus apparentés aux
strass cov 2 l'un serait plus rapprochée
génétiquement que ceux connus jusqu'à ce
jour mais ces virus sont encore éloignés
du virus proximale recherché et ne
possède pas une des caractéristiques
génétiques clé attendu
[Applaudissements]
plus les mois passent plus les chances
de trouver l'ancêtre immédiat du sras
skov deux teams in et n'a à présent la
recherche de lots intermédiaires est
devenu extrêmement compliqué à cause de
la transmission d'humain à animal
trouvé un animal sauvage pourtant eu les
russes identique à
99,99 pour cent est ce vraiment un
ancêtre du strass co2 ou bien va rien
alors entre tâche est devenue vraiment
plus difficile
les échantillons de la banque de sang de
one ne sont conservées que deux ans les
animaux d'élevage meurent les indices
s'évapore genevois ils se sont évaporés
pendant la nuit le soleil se lève et les
indices ont disparu ils ont disparu
maintenant ça fait 18 mois
malgré cet effort international le flou
plane encore sur les premiers moments de
cette pandémie qui a causé plus de 4
millions de morts les clés sont détenus
par la chaîne sans sa coopération la
recherche de l'origine du virus on
arrive à une impasse we are asking
actualité china tube
qui essaient d'en faire un enjeu
politique sont ceux qui ne veulent pas
connaître l'origine du virus car si vous
voulez trouver son origine vous ne
prenez pas cette approche c'est ce que
le ms leur demande voulez vous vraiment
connaître l'origine du virus où
voulez-vous juste faire de la politique
au printemps 2000 21 sans preuve
tangible de l'origine naturelle du virus
de plus en plus de scientifiques et de
politiciens prennent au sérieux
l'hypothèse de laboratoire les
frustrations de police de vienne public
la colère monte
après la pause d expérience risquée par
des conditions de biosécurité
insuffisante
[Musique]
prêtant 2021 d'un côté les découvertes
dérangeante de drastiques s'accumulent
ils font l'objet de publications
scientifiques
de l'autre les preuves de l'origine
naturelle demeure introuvable au mieux
aux antiquités orientales
le principal argument qui demeure la
confiance inébranlable de grands
virologiste en verre chez only à l'achat
c'est une virologue de renom elle publie
des articles depuis des décennies sur
des nouveaux coronavirus de
chauves-souris genevois tout simplement
pas une telle personne est impliquée
dans un complot une conspiration
line found ami de longue date de chez
annie lille à des fins
en janvier 2020 gta ou one je parlais à
son équipe avant même que le monde ne
commence à émettre l'hypothèse d'une
fuite de labo j'ai posé des questions
j'ai moi même mené les enquêtes et
j'étais convaincu qu'il n'y avait aucune
possibilité
cette pandémie est d'une telle ampleur
que nous pouvons pas simplement nous
contenter de la parole d'une
scientifique donc fait confiance mais
vérifier n'est ce pas ali natcan
organise une lettre réclamant une
véritable enquête internationale avec
une attention égale porté à la fête de
laboratoire
mieux elle a employé une approche douce
avec la chine ça n'a pas fonctionné
alors beaucoup de scientifiques quand
ils ont vu les résultats se sont dit
nous avons vraiment besoin d'une enquête
crédible pour trouver la réponse
cette fois à linate chat n'est plus seul
des scientifiques de renom unissent leur
voix à la sienne en mai 2021 la lettre
est publiée dans la prestigieuse revue
science cet appui formel des
scientifiques pour la thèse l'a fait de
laboratoire marque un point tournant
dans la discussion publique de los
primature push to reduce jouanno vie à
la tuerie deux semaines plus tard le
nouveau président américain joe biden
donne 90 jours aux services de
renseignement pour enquêter sur les
véritables origines du virus
[Musique]
mais admettre qu'une fuite est possible
c'est forcer l'ouverture de la boîte de
pandore l'examen de conscience à lui en
particulier aux états unis le moteur
financier mondial de la recherche sur le
gan fonction des modifications
génétiques parfois risquées sur des
virus dangereux pourtant dénoncée depuis
plus de 20 ans et les fonctions
en février 2021 au sénat le docteur
anthony facci est confronté sur le
financement américain des expériences de
gan fonctions à l'institut de virologie
de wuhan
le sénateur obando fait référence à ces
articles scientifiques l'un publié en
2015 menée aux états unis en
collaboration avec l'institut
d'hydrologie de one et l'autre publié en
2010 est mené à one dans les deux il est
écrit que ces études sont financées par
le naïade dont anthony facci et le
directeur
malgré cela le docteur pham chi un
défenseur de longue date du gan fonction
ni nos
fans game of food research
and your own institute of china il a
donc un très fort intérêt personnel un
très fort conflit d'intérêts à entraver
ces discussions et c'est pourquoi il a
menti encore et encore et encore
le biologiste et bright se bat depuis
plus de vingt ans pour une meilleure
régulation des expériences de gan
fonctions ce financement américain est
d'autant plus compromettants qu'une
partie aurait été accordée alors qu'ils
étaient en vigueur un moratoire sur le
financement des expériences de gamme
fonctions
ce travail a été mené puis publié
pendant le moratoire
le plus frappant est qu'après que les
résultats étaient publiés et rapporter
aux agences de financement ces agences
ont encore failli à interrompre ce type
de travaux en drap de scrat
le gouvernement américain se défend
up and
not being in aux fonctions c'est une
bataille de définition
line found siège sur le comité
consultatif scientifique de l'institut
de virologie de one il refuse de
qualifier leur expérience de gan
fonctions je n'aime pas le terme gain de
fonction nous modifions certaines
composantes génétiques pour voir comment
se comporte le virus le gain de fonction
c'est que vous modifiez délibérément le
virus tout en sachant qu'il deviendra
plus virulents
richard et bright comme d'autres est en
désaccord le moratoire a utilisé pour
des fictions les activités de recherche
pour lesquelles il est raisonnable
d'anticiper une augmentation de la
transmissibilité ou de la pathogénicité
d'un virus de la grippe du strass ou dit
m ce qui importe ce n'est donc pas ce
que les résultats sont réputés que les
résultats pourraient perdre est est ce
que c'était pour vous du gan fonctions
yes
simon wayne hobson dénoncent les risques
de la recherche sur le guen fonction
depuis plus d'une décennie et vous
l'utilisez le mini pression de
laboratoires pour fait un virus qui nous
fait pas l'homme qui est pas vous vos
interventions est désormais une facture
trop long ça c'est guen fonctions
pour plusieurs le financement de
l'institut de virologie de one pendant
ce moratoire est la preuve d'un laxisme
du gouvernement américain et richard et
bright a recensé plusieurs autres prêche
la subvention qui a soutenu ce travail
c'est l'une des trois quatre douzaines
qui aurait dû être suspendu mais qu'ils
n'ont pas été car l' agence de
financement a failli à les identifier
comme du gain de fonction
cette incapacité à identifier ces
recherches à haut risque inquiète
d'autant plus qu'elle s'ajoute selon
plusieurs un manque d'encadrement des
conditions biosécurité
l'institut de virologie a souvent mis
l'accent sur son nouveau laboratoire de
sécurité maximale de niveau p4 et ses
mesures exceptionnelles de sécurité
il ya eu beaucoup d'attention médiatique
sur les laboratoires de niveau p4 les
laboratoires de sécurité maximale mais
ces recherches dont nous discutons ici
n'ont pas eu lieu dans ses laboratoires
elles ont eu lieu à des niveaux de
sécurité inférieur en p2 et p3
de l'aveu même de shengli en entrevue et
selon ses publications
ces recherches sont menées en p2
seulement
lorsque drastique attire l'attention sur
ces conditions c'est le choc
les deux vous portez un sarraus de
laboratoire des gants des lunettes ce
n'est pas très différent de laboratoires
universitaires ou de dentiste c'est un
niveau de sécurité très bas
un séjour dont turin laboratoires p2 est
totalement inadéquat pour des travaux
avec un virus qui a les caractéristiques
de transmission du strass co2 c'est
totalement inadéquat pour tout agent
pathogène potentiellement pandémique qui
se transmet par aérosol
ici vous avez les plus grands virologues
qui tente délibérément de rendre ces
virus plus dangereux qu'ils réussissent
à le faire et qui accepte malgré tout
ils peuvent le faire un haut niveau de
sécurité plus bas que le maximum
aucune loi n'empêche et chercheurs de
mener ses expériences parmi les plus
risqués qui existe dans ses laboratoires
de moindre sécurité j'ai donc travaillé
au musée 2 ne violait aucune loi sans
violer même aucune directive c'était
tout simplement placer ses propres
intérêts au dessus des intérêts du reste
de la place
et rien ni personne ne forçait
laboratoire à divulguer la nature de
leurs travaux leur carnet de notes et
les accidents survenus des pratiques qui
auraient permis de lever le doute sur
les expériences menées à l'institut de
virologie
il n'y a aucune règle ou réglementations
internationales autour de ce type de
recherche ce n'est donc pas qu'ils ne
l'ont pas divulguer à un organisme
international il n'y a aucune obligation
pour ce laboratoire de le divulguer au
niveau international
il y a lieu de s'inquiéter des
conditions de biosécurité à l'institut
de virologie de hoàn comme l'ont révélé
des câbles diplomatiques américains
divulgués par le washington post
il révèle une inquiétude profonde
l'ambassadeur américain à pékin le 19
janvier 2018 il note un manque important
de techniciens adéquatement formés pour
opérer les laboratoires
bca aussi que la mise en place de ces
établissements un haut niveau de
biosécurité et plus récentes en chine et
qu'il y a eu moins de temps pour qu'une
culture de biosécurité ne se développer
cet été l'espoir de trouver une réponse
était entre les mains du service de
renseignement américains en ou après
trois mois d'enquêté ils déposent leurs
abords
des
idées
non plus ne parviennent pas à trancher
les 17 agences impliquées sont
profondément divisés
l'om est entamé une phase ii à la
recherche de l'origine du virus louis
mib une formation au noir de citrouilles
chesnoff des slops whaou mais la chine
s'y oppose
voici là où nous en sommes deux
hypothèses beaucoup de spéculations
aucune preuve définitive
pour démontrer une origine naturelle la
pièce marquante et la trace d'un virus
progéniteurs dans un autre intermédiaire
ou dans la chaîne d'approvisionnement du
marché du wan pour une faute de
laboratoire ce serait dans les bases de
données ou des carnets d'expérience des
laboratoires dans les deux cas on peut
obtenir ses preuves ni parle en quête de
l'om s ni par aucune autre régulation
internationale en biosécurité c'est ce
que nous avons appris de l'étude des
origines de l'aco vide c'est que l' oms
n'a pas le pouvoir d'investiguer il
semble n'y avoir aucun mécanisme
international pour retracer les origines
les russes c'est ce qu'on a vu à travers
toute cette saga c'est qu'un pays peut
simplement dire non et il est alors
impossible de les redresser sans
mécanismes efficaces pour enquêter les
fuites de laboratoire ou les origines
des épidémies on est condamné à
reproduire le passé ou même à faire pire
[Musique]
après la pause prévenir la prochaine
ford in
[Musique]
juillet 2021 c'est au tour de pékin de
réclamer à l'om est ce une investigation
cette fois des laboratoires américains
logiciels
audio
d'autres rappellent que des laboratoires
menant des expériences risques et il
s'en trouve dans bien d'autres pays ce
problème d' accident de laboratoire
n'est pas spécifique à la chine ça peut
arriver dans n'importe quel pays où on
travaille avec des pathogènes à
potentiel pandémique
philippe alan doss a publié cette année
une cartographie mondiale des
laboratoires haute sécurité de type p 4
là où on manipule les pathogènes les
plus dangereux de la planète
elle dénombre 59 laboratoire de sécurité
maximale de type p 4 répartis dans 23
pays et il n'existe encore aucune
estimation du nombre de laboratoires de
type p 3
dénombrant forte croissance depuis 2001
il ya une forme de course aux armements
d'établissement à haut niveau de
biosécurité qui a commencé par les
efforts américains en réponse aux
attaques terroristes du 11 septembre et
aux envois postaux d'anthrax
philippe à la sauce a recensé les
mesures de biosécurité qui régissent les
laboratoires pk existants les trois
quarts ne respectent pas les meilleures
pratiques de biosécurité ce qui signifie
qu'il ya plusieurs pays qui pourraient
améliorer leurs mesures de bio sûreté et
de biosécurité
l'enjeu est d'autant plus inquiétant que
la multiplication de ces laboratoires
haute sécurité devrait s'accélérer
il n'y aura plus d'accent mise sur la
préparation et la réponse aux pandémies
dans le futur
le nombre de laboratoires de niveau p4
mais aussi p3 devrait augmenter de
manière spectaculaire au cours des
prochaines années
à l'été 2000 20 en pleine pandémie la
chaîne a annoncé la construction d'une
vingtaine de nouveau laboratoire p4 et
88 laboratoire p3 plus on a deux
laboratoires de team bissell 4 bien plus
on a travaillé sur des virus qui
potentiellement sont très dangereuses
dans l'espèce humaine
et les accidents de laboratoire son
cours a cédé 6
on en a vu partout dans le monde aux
états unis de h5n1 d'anthrax au royaume
uni de variole en europe de prion de
vache folle sans le strass 1 par exemple
a fui de laboratoire sifwat une fois à
singapour une fois à taïwan de
laboratoire p4 donc du plus haut niveau
de biosécurité et jusqu'à 4 fois de
l'institut de recherche de pékin
inexorablement en avance vers le jour
que nous avons des ça c'était made in de
l'auberge si c'est pas maintenant sa
tion trois ans en cinq ans la puissance
de feu que technique génétique collard
c'est incroyable
l'astronef face au 21ème siècle mais les
humains fabriquent leurs propres rangs
russes ont les collectionne on y cultive
en grand nombre on les reconduit non les
modifie cela pose de nouveaux risques
en 2017 les états unis ont levé le
moratoire sur les expériences de gan
fonctions
en imposant des évaluations de risques
et bénéfices pour toute nouvelle
expérience
une politique qui n'est pas appliquée
selon richard wright we do et aux etats
unis nous avons sur papier une politique
mais depuis sa création un seul projet a
été évalué alors que deux ou trois
douzaines aurait dû l'être
la responsabilité de l'évaluation des
risques bénéfices aux scientifiques eux
mêmes et à leurs institutions à mon avis
c'est insuffisant
si l'on veut prévenir la prochaine
pandémie une réflexion s'impose peu
importe la provenance du virus qui
causent la pandémie actuelle
qu'elles soient liées à la destruction
des habitats écologiques et le commerce
des espèces sauvages ou aux expériences
dangereuse en laboratoire sans
encadrement suffisant une masse noeuds
de vent de manière urgente minimiser les
vulnérabilités de ces deux voies
d'entrée possibles des virus dans la
population humaine nous sommes dans une
situation analogue à celle suivant une
catastrophe aérienne
le moteur gauche peut avoir été
défectueux ou celui de droite nous
devons réparer les deux et pas juste un
seul
sans quoi nous reverrons cela de notre
vivant
[Musique]
nous devons nous assurer dans
nationalement qu'internationalement que
nous disposons de mécanismes solides de
surveillance des risques biologiques
qu'ils sont correctement appliquées et
qu'on développe des cultures de bio
sûreté et de biosécurité où les
chercheurs sont conscients des risques
des recherches qu'il mène tiens je reste
aof de work at elle dit
on
j'espère que les scientifiques comme les
non scientifiques trouveront une façon
de ramener cela à une conversation
équilibrée des polarisée et non
politisée je sais que nous sommes
profondément plongés dans la politique
en ce moment tout le monde se blâment
les ans les autres nous devons trouver
une façon de désamorcer cette
conversation
cette vaste enquête internationale des
autres institutions des nations les plus
puissantes des scientifiques et
internautes rebelles ce travail n'a pas
permis de trouver ce qu'on cherchait
l'origine du virus mais il nous a appris
beaucoup sur les failles béantes en
biosécurité et en législation sur les
faiblesses de l' oms et comment même
dans les plus hautes sphères de la
science il peut être difficile de
discuter ouvertement et rationnellement
je crois que ça a été une discussion
inutilement difficile pour les
scientifiques ce casse alors qu'en
vérité la recherche de l'origine de
nouveaux virus aurait dû être à
l'avantagé de tous
wada puisque je vais continuer à
m'impliquer sur cette question ce n'est
pas clair il est maintenant temps que
des experts plus réputés prennent les
choses en main et montrer au monde que
les meilleurs scientifiques peuvent
enquêter de manière impartiale sur les
origines du virus et je ne suis pas
cette personne je suis une post hoc une
apprentie scientifique
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine à découverte
changement climatique effet en 2018 on a
battu les records de feux de forêts dans
le monde entier
voilà c'est ainsi que se terminent les
missions d'aujourd'hui de la part de
toute l'équipe merci d'avoir été là
bonsoir
[Musique]